welcome back to New rockstars my name is
Anna vanston and the Five Nights at
Freddy's trailer just came out and there
is a lot here so here's what we're gonna
do this video will be breaking it down
in a way that's free of spoilers for
people who haven't played the games and
then later we'll be releasing a video
where we go along with game spoilers and
theorizing about the timeline and plot
of this movie and I got some theories so
be sure to subscribe so you don't miss
that and thank you to boxu for
sponsoring this video we'll get back to
them in a minute and also in the teaser
breakdown I did accidentally
mispronounce Scott coffin's name and
although is a pretty damn cool name if
you ask me I do apologize for the error
and if you can forgive past Markiplier
you can forgive me but fair's fair so
for this video in this video Only You
may call me Anna Van store in the
comments which isn't nearly as cool also
before I hop in secret invasion is here
so be sure to tune in to new rockstars
every Wednesday for our secret Invasion
breakdowns and there's even more secret
Invasion discussion on our newest
channel the break room that show is
filled with conspiracies research walls
and more crazy details and we'll be
breaking it all down on new rockstars
and the break room
hi this is Mike I was just calling this
calling us that you offered was still
available yes the security guard I will
take anything at the start of the
trailer we can see Mike played by Josh
Hutcherson coming home to a notice of
delinquency which is a legal warning of
an overdue mandatory payment oftentimes
this is in regards to child support and
although Jessica Blackmore is credited
as Mike's mom on IMDb the lack of
Parental figure around and the fact that
Mike has to take his sister with him to
work leads me to believe that Mike is
the one with custody of Abby we see
later in the trailer that Mike Works
security at a mall and presumably lost
his job for taking this guy to Pound
Town that's
so this desperate need to earn money
under the legal threat of losing
possession of his sister is what drives
him to take the security guard position
at Freddy Fazbear's Pizza place we also
get another look at William Afton played
by Matthew Lillard who is apparently
going by the Alias Steve Ragland working
as a career counselor now it seems odd
that someone in debt would have the
money to hire a career counselor so
likely either William offered his
services to Mike or was supplied by the
state perhaps because of this particular
custody case or if Mike's still in
school it might be the school's career
counselor I'll head deeper into this
mystery in my next theorizing video
this place was
huge shut it down years ago the owner is
just not ready to let it go yet I will
work and you will sleep I understand
come here in
we then see the same closed sign we saw
in the teaser with five letters together
one letter apart and one red letter
which screams symbolism to me and we
hear William say they shut it down years
ago the owner's just not ready to let it
go yet now this is clearly an edited
audio line but for all intents and
purposes it's setting up why a security
guard is still watching over an
abandoned building and right on cue the
pizzeria's new security guard Mike pulls
up to the building with Abby played by
Piper Rubio who notably has a teddy bear
though to specifically not a Freddy bear
Mike has a voiceover saying I will work
and you will sleep affirming that Mike
has to bring his sister Along on his
night shifts because there's no one else
who can look after her we get some shots
that we analyzed in our teaser breakdown
including the pictures commonly seen on
the walls in the games and the Freddy
stained glass panel that we thought we
spotted along with a shadow of Foxy
all you have to do
is keep your eyes on the monitor
welcome to Freddy Fazbear's where
fantasy and fun come to life
okay we see a couple of mice and event
reminiscent of the phrase like rats in a
maze an expression used to describe
feeling trapped or being controlled and
experimented on by an unseen Observer
Maps these two siblings all but rats and
I maze we see Mike looking around the
security office your home base in the
first game which includes a red light
first seen in Five Nights at Freddy's 3
and an employee of the month board that
serves to Cameo several YouTubers that
have a history of covering the game
series including but not limited to doco
8-bit Ryan Fusion Z gamer Bez and
rezbowski as Mike starts up an
introductory VHS tape Williams voiceover
says all you have to do is keep your
eyes on the monitor a tongue-in-cheek
way of describing the gameplay of the
first game as well minus all the button
pushing that keeps you from getting
killed
boxes put the best snacks from Japan in
the palm of your hand look at these
cuties look at them your first box will
be Seasons of Japan and after that you
receive a new theme every month there's
even a little booklet to tell you what's
tasty you know what the pink one and
this mochan dangle Mochi is tasty tasted
boxing makes a great gift for you for
someone else for anybody who loves
snacks so if you want to try boxu and
support the channel click the link in
the description and use code rockstars
to get 15 off your order then the new
higher instructional video plays which
we actually broke down in the first
teaser video down to the models of the
games in it too if you haven't seen that
first breakdown give it a watch there's
a lot of interesting stuff in there
foreign
help you officer have you met them yet
who
damn
we then see Vanessa played by Elizabeth
lale buzzing in waving at the camera to
show she's not a threat as Mike lets her
in we see that she is in fact a police
officer as we predicted in our last
video we can tell that Vanessa has some
connection to this place from the very
first thing she says You must be the new
security guard implies that she's in the
loop enough to know when they've made a
new hire and her next line have you met
them yet indicates she knows a lot more
than one might expect we see a fridge
with a kid's drawing of the animatronics
and three people on it who else
speculate about in the next video but
the blue shirt with the high collar and
what looks like a badge makes me think
that this is Vanessa but Mike does not
in fact keep his eyes on the monitors as
we then see him with his eyes closed and
headphones on followed by him sleeping
on the desk he had one job Mike Mike is
rudely awoken from a slumber as the
monitor start flashing in the toriador
song from Carmen a common theme song for
Five Nights at Freddy's blast through
the speakers we see the lights going
crazy in the restaurant powering up and
amidst the flashes some little things
you can spot or a visit Nebraska poster
a CCTV camera and a little toy Bonnie in
the corner in the next shots we can see
more of the arcade and can I just say I
would have been pissed if I was the last
kid who used this crane game that's
messed up and the price counter with the
masks and toys that we called out in our
teaser breakdown 2 000 tickets for that
chica mask I'll take the 200 Tootsie
Rolls please we also see a snippet of
the animatronic stage show before
Bonnie's guitar sparked and then
everything goes back to normal as Mike
was either about to turn the power off
or has just done the old turn it off and
back on again trick hard to tell which
but either way it's in the on position
in this shot regardless we then see him
using the control board to flip between
security cameras like the main mechanic
in the game including similar shots and
even a one for one shot of the
animatronics then we get into the meat
of the movie in the 80s kids went
missing
the police searched Freddy's top to
bottom hello
they never found them Vanessa explains
that kids went missing in the 80s and
were never found as were shown the
menacing dilapidated frame of fox oxy
and the limp hand of a body being
dragged across the floor when it cuts
back to Vanessa one fun detail is that
to the left if you turn up the
brightness you can see a magnet or a
sticker of a hazard sign with an
exclamation mark that is commonly seen
throughout the games we then see Abby
walking hesitantly across the main party
room and giving a hello that is super
reminiscent of balloon boy's hello in
Five Nights at Freddy's 2. hello as she
approaches the sage and looks at Freddy
through a part in the curtain we can
hear the sound of a child's laugh and
then we see Freddy's eyes light up in
the Darkness
that's why the play shut down
there are ghost children possessing
giant robots
thanks for the heads up
technically they're animatronics
much perhaps the real Mischief happens
in the daytime as we see four people
including three listed as Carl Hank and
Max on IMDb break into Freddy's Hank
with a bat and the person in front
holding a crowbar one thing I think is
really interesting about this is that
Scott cawthon made a Reddit post when
the script was finished where he talked
about ideas he had for previous
iterations of the screenplay and two
notable ones were a group of
troublemakers breaking into Freddy's and
a group of ghost trackers sneaking into
Freddy's at the end of the post he also
mentions that a script had the best
pieces from all the previous screenplays
so I wonder if that was what this part
of the movie was inspired by but it
doesn't look like this group has a
particularly good time as we then see
Hank trapped in the janitorial closet
with Bonnie and Nod to how Bonnie is the
only one who appears in the Supply
Closet in the first game then it's
Wood's time as we get a dirt drawing of
spring Bonnie a new character to the
trailer that I'll get more into in the
future spoilers video and the ghost
children that we saw in the teaser see
it just goes show how I take care of
y'all who are new to the series of
course I knew there were ghost children
possessing the animatronics but I had to
wait for them to say but now I have
Misty's and if you missed the last video
they represent Bonnie foxy Chica and
then there's still a huge amount of
debate around which kid is supposed to
represent Freddy and which is supposed
to represent golden Freddy Maybe ages
maybe I'll throw my hat in the ring
pardon the pun in the next video
what do they want they want to make her
like them puppy
tell me how to stop them
it's too late
we get a single flash of Foxy standing
outside of the security office and then
Abby walking through the entrance of the
main play area before we see her looking
at the drawing wall with the one in the
center highlighted this picture looks to
be spring Bonnie with five children that
match up with the ghost children from
the previous shots while Vanessa's
voiceover is saying they want to make
her like them we can see that Abby is in
the background of the shot with foxy
looking at him Mike runs through
assumedly them all judging by the mall
security shirt he's wearing and then we
get a scene where Max one of the people
who broke in earlier is looking down the
barrel of a Freddy head and we hear a
child laugh before a hand shoots out of
the mouth originally I thought this was
one of those classic teen horror movie
moments where it's like it's just a
prank hand it was just a prank hand and
it's her friend trying to scare but
those boots in the following shot of
someone being lifted off of a chair do
in fact match hers from the earlier shot
so if this is all from the same scene
that might just be a symbolic ghosty
hand because it would take a lot of
upper body strength to lift a person
like that we see Foxy's foot crutch a
ball pit ball as the lights turn purple
I'd be hiding behind an arcade cabinet
the animatronics on stage with chica
seemingly missing and our first live
glance at Spring Bonnie
[Music]
then at the end they throw all the
spaghetti at the wall as we get flashes
of a child in the back seat who I will
definitely talk about in the theory
video a woman on the ground who from the
matching carpet from the earlier shots
might be Mike's mom and also note the
newspaper on the table interesting
Vanessa in the hospital with Mike
visiting that scene of Mike beating up a
guy in the malls Fountain my crawling
through event Vince playing an integral
role in the game series a closer shot of
spring Bonnie this time with a knife
Mike's trying to escape through a back
door only to find it locked and then
that scene from the teaser with him
locked in a chair with a razor-laden
Freddy head coming towards him
where to
why do I always get the weirdos
finally we see a taxi cab driven by
YouTuber Corey X Kenshin it has a phone
number on it and fun fact a lot of times
in movies and TV shows you'll see phone
numbers starting with 555 and that's
because most 555 numbers don't connect
to an actual number so there's no chance
of someone accidentally getting their
number publicized in the back seat is
golden Freddy and Abby and his apparent
closeness to her gives me big Vibes that
he's gonna look to her to help free the
kids Souls but that's just speculation
and I'll do a whole lot more speculation
in our future video where we're really
gonna dive into the deep end for fans of
the series as I said before be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss that in the
meantime you can follow me on Twitter at
it'sanavanston follow And subscribe to
new rockstars at new rockstars and hey
if you like live discussions debates and
reactions to the titles you can't get
enough of be sure to subscribe to our
live channel the break room alright I've
got some Tootsie Rolls to eat 200 of
them wish you what